quando mi chiedono
mestiere faccio non riesco mai a dare
una risposta diretta immediata
comprensibile non un gran biglietto da
visita per uno che si occupa di
comunicazione di giornalismo
divulgazione scientifica divulgazione
dei cambiamenti climatici
ma se io volessi dare una risposta
chiara diretta dovrei dire che io sono
un ladro perché io rubo io rubo
informazioni rubo dati io rubo parole e
le rubo a scienziati ad esperti a
ricercatori a gente che spende il
proprio tempo ad affrontare questioni
complesse a sviscerarle ad approfondire
la conoscenza ea metterla a disposizione
ea farlo con l'accuratezza ed il rigore
che il metodo scientifico richiede
tra le questioni complesse i cambiamenti
climatici sono una di quelle che oggi ci
sembrano più rilevanti quella che
vengono definite come una delle sfide
più avanzate dei nostri giorni e secondo
me è una buona definizione questa sapete
perché
perché da una parte la ricerca
scientifica che ha una ricerca molto
complessa che mette insieme tante
discipline ci dice che le nostre
attività le nostre vite
il modo con cui ci spostiamo produciamo
energia riscaldiamo le nostre case
produce queste attività producono
l'anidride carbonica e il gas serra che
immessi in atmosfera contribuiscono e
sono i maggiori responsabili dei
cambiamenti climatici ossia
dell'innalzamento della temperatura del
pianeta e da qui una serie di eventi
quali l'intensificarsi di eventi estremi
e alimenti estremi piogge intense sempre
più dolente oppure periodi siccitosi più
caldi o più imprevedibili a sua volta
però questi eventi
che cosa fanno influenzano la nostra
vita perché affrontare questi eventi e
cercare di limitarli cercare di ridurli
vuol dire che dobbiamo in qualche modo
modificare il modo in cui viviamo
il modo in cui produciamo energia il
modo in cui trasportiamo noi stesse le
nostre merci
il nostro rapporto con il cibo con
l'acqua ma ancora agricoltura turismo
persino sport il tempo libero
vi sfido trovate un aspetto della nostra
vita che non abbia a che fare con i
cambiamenti climatici
ora per affrontare questa complessità
gli scienziati utilizzano parole
complesse parole difficili settoriali
spesso sigle e acronimi parole in lingue
straniere e fanno bene perché il loro
compito è quello di approfondire
attraverso il metodo scientifico e
produrre conoscenza e non c'è un'altra
via per produrre conoscenza devono fare
questo ma allo stesso tempo il clima
cambia per tutti non cambia solo per gli
scienziati e quindi anche noi dobbiamo
avere la capacità di capire quanto tocca
la nostra vita questa interazione
reciproca tra il clima che cambia
e i nostri sistemi socio economici cioè
la nostra vita quotidiana
per questo io rubo le loro parole rubo
le parole agli scienziati
parliamoci chiaro se le fanno rubare
tranquillamente lo sanno che le rughe
sanno che io le riutilizzo insieme ad
altre persone
a quale scopo con lo scopo di costruire
con altre parole che magari conosciamo
bene che fanno parte del nostro
linguaggio comune un racconto dentro il
quale i cambiamenti climatici siano i
protagonisti e ci facciano entrare
dentro questa interazione questa
connessione tra il clima e la nostra
vita
la prima di queste parole il pianeta è
il palcoscenico di tutta questa storia
ma neanche un
protagonista a volte suona addirittura
come una vittima
pensateci pensate titoli di giornali
quando parlano dei cambiamenti climatici
dobbiamo salvare il pianeta
stiamo distruggendo il pianeta ultimatum
per salvare la terra sul serio voi
pensate davvero che noi salviamo il
pianeta è una domanda che mi faccio
spesso nel mio lavoro e per rispondere
c'è secondo me bisogno di un punto di
vista esterno cioè distaccarsi un po
ovviamente io non posso farlo ma c'è chi
è nella posizione privilegiata di farlo
un afro nauta che guardando la terra
fisicamente da una posizione distaccata
da una stazione spaziale ha pensato
queste parole e ha detto in un attimo la
terra può guardarci e dire che mi frega
sparite e scrollarci di dosso come
pidocchi altro che salvare la terra
il punto secondo me è questo qua che il
pianeta è abituato ai cambiamenti non
siamo noi che stiamo portando i primi
cambiamenti al pianeta il pianeta
abituato a reagire ai cambiamenti
il punto è che per la prima volta
noi siamo i responsabili di questi
cambiamenti per la prima volta abbiamo
la conoscenza per sapere dove ci portano
questi cambiamenti per sapere gli
impatti che questi cambiamenti producono
per la nostra vita per sapere anche
quali soluzioni abbiamo a disposizione
possiamo costruire per limitare questi
impatti
la questione è che per la prima volta
dentro questi cambiamenti ci siamo noi
qualche esempio banca mondiale uno
studio dello scorso anno ha valutato che
nel 2050 i cambiamenti climatici ai loro
impatti negativi possono contribuire a
produrre 140 milioni di migranti interni
quindi dentro i confini nazionali
nelle aree più popolose del pianeta
america latina sud dell'asia africa sub
sahariana 140 milioni di immigranti ma
non è una questione che riguarda solo i
paesi meno meno ricchi stati uniti
no a la l'agenzia che si occupa dello
studio degli oceani e dell'atmosfera ha
calcolato che negli ultimi 40 anni
gli eventi estremi piogge intense
alluvioni uragani siccità e ondate di
calore hanno prodotto danni per 1.700
miliardi di dollari vogliamo venire
ancora più vicino a casa nostra
attraversiamo l'oceano europa agenzia
europea per l'ambiente
nello stesso periodo eventi eventi
estremi e venti intensi hanno causato
qua danni per 453 miliardi di euro ora
non prendetemi avere una persona troppo
venare che parlo di soldi ma leggete
dietro quelle cifre
leggete malfunzionamenti dei sistemi
sono socio sanitarie leggete servizi
attività produttive che devono
interrompere loro attività leggete case
perse leggete disagi per la vita di
tutti i giorni
è questo che voglio che vogliono dire
quei soldi la domanda è vera e allora
quanto siamo disposti a spendere e per
cosa
per rispondere a questa domanda c'è
bisogno di informazioni di dati di
informazioni molto precise e sono le
informazioni che ci dà la scienza come
fanno gli scienziati del clima a
studiare il clima lepre le esperimenti
sul clima si possono fare in un solo
modo ossia costruendo una terra virtuale
come attraverso dei modelli numerici
gli scienziati usano delle operazioni
molto complicate che simulano il
comportamento del clima e del pianeta
terra nel futuro e costruiscono degli
scenari futuri se nel 2100 la
concentrazione di gas serra in atmosfera
sarà di
molto elevata il clima cambierà in un
certo modo se invece attueremo delle
operazioni per renderla meno elevata
il clima cambierà in un altro modo con
altre impatti sulle nostre vite sulle
nostre società per fare tutto questo
la scienza ha bisogno di una tecnologia
molto avanzata
ogni generazione di modelli climatici
rubo le parole ad antonio navarra che è
un climatologo il fondatore del cmcc
ogni generazione di modelli di modelli
climatici è come un grande telescopio
una generazione successiva di un
telescopio che ci permette di vedere
meglio ma non vedere meglio le stelle in
questo caso ci permette di vedere in
maniera più dettagliata e più nitida il
futuro del nostro pianeta
qui vedete i modelli nel corso degli
ultimi 30 anni vede rita in alto a
sinistra come la definizione sgranata e
vedete come migliora la definizione la
nitidezza dell'immagine
questo vuol dire che siamo capaci di
sapere e di simulare il clima con una
capacità di con un'esattezza maggiore
rispetto a 30 anni fa per fare questo
sono necessarie dei computer molto
potenti che riescono a sviluppare una
grande capacità di calcolo ad esempio
quello che utilizziamo al cmcc ha una
capacità di calcolo a picco dell'ordine
dei petaflops ossia milioni di miliardi
di operazioni al secondo
la tecnologia
la scienza ha bisogno della tecnologia
per produrre conoscenza così come ha
bisogno della tecno così come la
tecnologia ci serve per creare le
soluzioni che ci risolvono il problema
pensiamo all'innovazione per
l'energia rinnovabile per l'efficienza
energetica delle nostre case per
utilizzare meno acqua possibile per in
campo in campo agricolo sono tutte
soluzioni che hanno bisogno di
tecnologia avanzata
capita però a volte che come la scienza
guarda la terra per simularla e per
darne un ritratto virtuale attraverso la
tecnologia la tecnologia guarda invece
alla natura per creare innovazione si
chiamano network based solutions
soluzioni basate sulla natura sono
iniziative che tendono a rendere le
nostre vite più resilienti ossia più
pronte ad affrontare gli impatti dei
cambiamenti climatici
ispirandosi e imitando la natura a volte
questa innovazione può essere banalmente
è semplicemente la natura stessa tetti
verdi prati sui nostri tetti potenziare
la presenza di verde nelle aree urbane
con l'effetto di avere con malcolm più
alberi ad esempio quelle che chiamano le
cinture verdi avere delle zone d ombra
che proteggono il nostro comfort quando
dico confort parlo anche di salute
pubblica di salute delle persone dalle
ondate di calore o che prati e piante
che in caso di pioggia intensa
trattengono l'acqua senza che lasciarla
defluire nelle strade creando quindi
disagio quindi a volte sembra banale ma
una tecnologia che abbiamo avuto sempre
davanti ai nostri occhi ci aiuta a
risolvere un problema che è molto
avanzato che appartiene ai nostri tempi
altre volte invece però la
questa innovazione ha bisogno di una
maggiore sofisticazione di un maggior
intervento dell'uomo
in questo caso vedete una piazza d'acqua
una water square
questa è quella che hanno fatto a
rotterdam sono piazze che in condizioni
normali sono ambienti polifunzionali in
campo da basket spazio per lo skate
board negozi passeggio aiuole prati
quando viene la pioggia intensa
la piazza è costruita in maniera tale
che l'acqua defluisce dentro questi
spazi creando dei bacini di raccolta
dell'acqua e così le strade sono libere
da potenziale alluvione perché l'acqua è
stata raccolta è stata messa da parte
vale la pena citare il caso di
copenaghen che è molto significativo
perché nel 2011 ha vissuto un evento
estremo una pioggia molto intensa
un evento che non accadeva da oltre 40
anni allora gli amministratori hanno
pensato di guardare agli scenari
climatici che dicevano che dovevano
aspettarsi nei prossimi anni un
intensificarsi della frequenza e
dell'intensità di questi eventi estremi
hanno adottato questi queste queste
soluzioni e nelle piogge successive
non che sono cadute per sei volte nei
successivi quattro anni non hanno avuto
i danni che hanno avuto nel 2011 in cui
una pioggia di due ore ha prodotto circa
un miliardo di euro di danni
in due ore e i danni sono sempre quelli
alle vite umane a un monetizzò per dare
per dare una quantità ora capite perché
dalla collaborazione tra scienza che
virtualizza il pianeta e ci parla del
futuro la tecnologia che imita la natura
noi riusciamo a capire a conoscere il
futuro per sapere cosa dobbiamo fare
oggi però queste nel sub solutions sono
alcune delle soluzioni che si possono
realizzare nelle nostre citta degli
nostri nei nostri
ma la questione climatica è anche una
questione planetaria la co2 che sta in
atmosfera e gas serra che stanno in
atmosfera riguardano tutto il pianeta e
non solo la nostra singola città
rubo ancora le parole a whelan nordhaus
premio nobel per l'economia del 2018 non
troveremo una soluzione senza avere
delle connessioni senza una
collaborazione internazionale non
riusciremo a risolvere il problema dei
cambiamenti climatici o comunque ad
affrontarlo con successo ossia
garantendo sviluppo sviluppo sostenibile
e cioè il benessere delle nostre
generazioni e l'opportunità di benessere
delle generazioni future
ecco concludo dicendo che io rubo parole
e le trasforma ma non mi pento non penso
di fare una cosa una cosa brutta perché
credo che valga la pena farlo se si
riesce a costruire un racconto in cui
emergano le interazioni tra la scienza e
la società tra la natura e la tecnologia
tra l'intero pianeta e la piccola
porzione di terra che occupiamo
quotidianamente grazie
[Applauso]